today I'm going to give a talk that's
entirely about ideas since we're we're
at big thing we could actually unleash
with mankind knows about the future the
web has become pretty clogged it's
becoming like you know pile of garbage
every time you do a search you get a
relevant search results will we lose an
old-school kind of technology Nets
talking face-to-face until you solve the
fixed cost problem you have a natural
monopoly and from a technology and
venture capital perspective the only
area we are looking at in search our
businesses that actually tackle that
core a fixed cost problem absolute
freedom from friction does tend to
create perverse incentives it creates
incentives for people to spam to deceive
we have google basically calling
microsoft out for cheating so microsoft
has said they don't copy the results and
you know we have screenshots that make
it look very much like that's happening
so i love if you guys could talk about
that it's not like we actually copy
anything it's really about so we learn
from the customers who actually
willingly opting to share the data with
this just like a Google that's just like
other search engines do what I'd like to
see in the web is it rather than me
trying to keep my computer happy and say
the right things that it wants to hear
so that it can respond to me then it
tells me what I want to know
you